Larry P Arn is the 12th president of
Hillsdale College he received his BA
from Arkansas State University and his
MA and PhD in government from the
claremont graduate school he served as
director of research for sir martin
gilbert the official biographer of
winston churchill from 1985 to 2000 he
served as president of the claremont
institute for the study of statesmanship
and political philosophy in 1996 he was
the founding chairman of the California
Civil Rights initiative it's proposition
209 which was passed by california
voters and prohibited racial preferences
in state hiring contracting and
admissions he is on the board of
directors of the Heritage Foundation the
Henry salvatori center of claremont
mckenna college and the claremont
institute he served on the US Army War
College Board of Visitors for two years
for which he earned the Department of
the Army's outstanding civilian Service
Medal and just recently he was also
awarded the prestigious Bradley prize
dr. Arnn is a member of the american
political science association the mont
pelerin society the international
churchill society and the philanthropy
roundtable published widely in national
newspapers magazines and periodicals on
issues of Public Policy history and
political theory he is the author of
several books including of liberty and
learning the evolution of American
education and the founders key the
divine and natural connection between
the Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution and what we risk by losing
it he's currently writing or i believe
is nearly finished a book on the
statesmanship in constitutionalism of
Winston Churchill dr. Aaron is a
professor of politics and history at
Hillsdale he teaches courses on
Aristotle on Winston Churchill and on
the American Constitution he and his
wife Penelope have four children Katie
Henry Alice and Tony please join me in
welcoming dr. Larry Arn
thank you welcome big day today thank
you James Holloman and the Chamber Choir
they're the mobile infantry and
artillery of the college and you'll get
to hear them a lot and that today they
were great but they'll be better when
they've had some practice and restore
the loss of the seniors that they lost
last time they were very good today kyle
is a star on the basketball team Thank
You Kyle he's a very bright young man a
professor ray and I have been pushing
him for years to be more ambitious and
he confirmed to me this morning that
he's applying for the road scholarship
and if they don't give him give it to
him they're idiots and Murray is also
very bright though not a star on the
men's basketball team and as she does
not have any defects of character unlike
Kyle that any of us has discovered i
need to welcome you here in the way that
we do it here because it's not just that
we're glad to have you why would we not
be glad to have you the freshmen are
young and they squirm and they don't
know anything it's absolutely delightful
young man in the student union mr. Grosz
Dale of California I said to him I said
why did you come here and he said well I
agree with the philosophy of the school
and I said what would philosophy be I
didn't ask him about that philosophy I
just wanted what the word means and of
course he eats quick young man so he
merely said I have no idea so he's quick
isn't he and that means that he's
learned the first step in college you
don't get to use words that you can't
define and that's hard work because you
got a lot to learn apart from welcome
are my purpose is to tell you what it is
because you have to join you parents are
going to stand up with your students and
you're going to take the parent
equivalent of our honor code that each
of your children has designed to come
here and you nobody's come here
for years that didn't sign it since the
day we put it in eight or nine or ten
years ago and that's commitment and it's
serious commitment and you have to make
the commitment and because you're free
people you need to understand what the
commitment is it's a sad day because
when I'm done we're going to say this
pledge that's in your program and then
those people in the green back there
that David mentioned are going to take
your kid away from you and you're going
to come up and have dinner with me which
is a bad trade and then the next time
you see your kid they're going to slip
and call this place home and that's
going to make you cry yet again and I
apologize for that but this is a good
college can't help it and you're part of
it on terms that i'm going to explain in
a minute since the word college means
partnership and since and because say
I'm just abusing the word since I sound
like Kyle Cooper and because a
partnership of learning is extremely
high and because partnerships can only
really work among three people if they
share purposes I need to state to you
the purposes of the college there are
four of them they are named in the first
three paragraphs of the founding
document there's not really any superior
or excellent institution of higher
learning founded for 2,000 years that
didn't have these four but there are
very few left that will talk about them
today the first is high learning what
does that mean what makes learning high
in the world today we look at the world
is horizontal we're all on everything's
on a flat plane and we're smack in the
middle of it it what's important is the
things we admire before this benighted
age everybody saw the universe is a vast
hierarchy one thing leads to another you
make something wise you can have the
something but why did you make the thing
in the first place because you wanted to
do something right so the making
its purpose and if you just walk up the
line pretty soon you'll get two things
that are just really good for their own
sake and have a high dignity and when
you name those even they are not enough
there's something beyond them that we
humans ache to know and have high
learning is about that and the greatest
books ever written a written about that
in the Natural Sciences the great
physicist there that they're known they
become known to people like me ordinary
humans in chemistry and biology and math
because they can reflect on those high
things they take their craft in there
the language that they can talk to a
place where nature itself becomes
comprehensible to them and you know
these freshmen they're going to be
putting together this huge jigsaw puzzle
and they don't know what in it where any
of the pieces go so it's hard you got to
work the college is a Christian College
it was founded by free will baptists a
long time ago that's been altered
because there weren't any free will
baptist hereafter in this part of the
world after about 60 years 70 years and
so then they added article 6 which says
the teaching of the Christian faith by
precept and example shall remain a
conspicuous aim of the college the
college supports free government in the
way proper to an institution of higher
learning that is to say it's not a
public policy shop it's a place where
people cultivate the virtues moral and
intellectual that can make them
excellent free citizens and understand
what that is and of course that is the
fundamental service to our Free Republic
and finally the college is committed to
moral behavior you parents will probably
be aware that at night when the students
here go to bed they have to say
goodnight and go to different buildings
that's a very odd
to do why do we do these things because
we argue that they are commanded from
above and because we think that they put
put together make a description of the
happy human being which means the human
being fully human all human elevated
because of that not clear that all of
that is going to be legal going forward
because the changes in the society are
simply huge now and the regulatory power
to enforce them is growing very fast and
what that means is the kind of thing we
do here has always been very difficult
to do and rare and beautiful in the
achievement of it and this college is
very successful you just saw those two
and they're just kids in a way but gosh
have they not grown up so much but now
there's this other thing and that is
this thing that we do here this complex
of things they require to be fought for
and we do fight for them and that's not
an unprecedented situation we have the
examples of our fathers to show us what
to do we require our self discipline and
our courage to carry on and you will
need those things too happy fact that
one of the ways to develop those traits
is to read about the people who've had
them and why they are in fact virtues
now your parents are going to take a
pledge in a minute and that that's
that's that means you're committed right
a few of the freshmen will call home
very lonely the success rates around
here are incredibly high it's not easy
to get in here all of your children are
going to say that it's very difficult
and yet nearly all of them are going to
succeed and be thrilled with the fact
that they came here but there'll be some
bumps on the road along the way you have
to remember you're on our side when we
have dinner I'll tell you some more
about what that means because we're
experienced at this and we know that you
are very important you're taking the
pledge is the fact and sign of your
inclusion will send you the kids grades
sometimes the kids don't like that their
kids to me right I I've got three
students that I've had in class who've
been clerks on the Supreme Court of the
United States and many PhDs now and
they're still kids to me and they always
will be but and we'll call them kids but
I remember a girl her name was raylene
co cynic and she said dr. Arnn why do
you send my grades to my parents they
don't have any money and I have paid for
all of my education and I said no
railing dear you have not done that I
have paid for most of it which is the
case with every kid we charge less than
half what it costs if you pay full
tuition and hardly any of you does it
means we're partners in this thing right
but raylene wouldn't stop and so I
caused the address line in her grades
when they went home to be to be changed
to the parents of the very mature and
independent ralink a cynic and I offer
any of you freshmen the same concession
what have you done new parents what does
it take to raise a human child you know
my wife and I there sits my wife she's
very nice she'll like her better than
you like me everybody does actually you
should stand up penny so they can
recognize you please
she she cooks for the students a lot
we've raised these four children just
like you right and you know if they were
dogs we raised dogs too we don't really
raise them they just live in our house
but a dog you know it's parents don't
know what it is in a few weeks and these
kids are all 18 years old and here you
said still doing your duty and the duty
is still painful to you that's human
biology right it's very demanding more
than most any creature and yet on the
other hand you didn't have to do this
you didn't have to have the kid you
didn't have to come here today you don't
have to help them through college you
don't have to do anything and yet they
need more than other kinds of creatures
from you everywhere in the world the
family is collapsing right now and yet
the persistent fact that you are here
and the data shows that kids do bear it
better when they are raised by their
parents it means you're used to doing
your duty aren't you how many how many
of you parents liked your child every
day that they were three years old I
don't mean loved I mean liked because
how could you like them will we
recognize that here and that means if
you come to parents weekend and they
come in droves 800 900 a thousand
parents at a time you will get 10
minutes with every teacher your child
has got and then the the conversations
are inspiring and useless because
usually we have parents weekend in the
middle of the term we don't really know
how their grades are at that time mostly
but we tell them you know we tell you
how great your kid is and you tell us
how great we are it's fun you should
come
also we don't get to use it today
because mr. pee-wee who's standing right
over there and builds all the buildings
is a week or two late getting our
fabulous new dining hall that'll see
this all and it's really beautiful and
so if you come to parents weekend you
can use that so remember parenthood and
college are a test and we're going to
take it together get ready we require
your help and I asked for it I'll say
just one more thing to the students
we're going to talk a lot the next week
Waylon and I are going to try to scare
the daylights out of you and we're
usually able what I want you to know is
we're going to be friends but we need
you if somebody sleeps in class it
wrecks the class doesn't happen here
very much but the work is long and hard
and there's so much fun to have and so
you've got to be serious about your work
you've got to think you've got to learn
you've got to read you've got to give it
your best effort you're obliged to do it
if you actually think that you didn't
come here to do that then don't stay as
we have said to you many times because
you're going to be surrounded by people
who are going to do that and I'm not
saying that in order to be tough on you
I don't set the standards anymore than
any of these people that all of your
going to get to know and you're going to
love them they have passed the test they
have studied for decades they are
learning and yet they adore to teach
young people who are just potential you
owe it to them and you owe it to
everyone else here too
your best every day and to live your
life so you can get you the best out of
yourself it's just like being on the
basketball team it means Kyle back there
is on two teams and he knows it and he
has to do right by both of them and the
college can be great if you do that and
it cannot be great unless you do think
how much depends on you don't think
we're going to coddle you and cozy you
we don't set the standards they exist in
nature we are all in a community to
attempt to meet them get your boots on
welcome